[Musique]
gascon
horbois
Genouillé lignage des noms énigmatiques
ce d'ancien sépag quels sont-ils
pourquoi ont-ils parfois
disparu quelles sont les raisons de leur
retour au premier
plan là c'est des viges plus que centen
de chez Colin
ition ok là on peut aussi aller sur des
plats soutenus il y a pas de problème
nous sommes dans l'entre d'un adepte de
ces anciens sépages un passionné en
quête de ses pieds de vigne méconnus ou
disparus ceux qui ont construit
l'histoire du vignoble du Val de
Loire j'avais goûté il y a très
longtemps du Pino de Nice sans savoir ce
que c'était et j'ai redécouvert un jour
ce goût et je me suis dit mais génial ça
ça a été ma madeleine de Prous j'ai
retrouvé le goût que j'avais eu il y a
quelques années en bouche et ça m'a
intéressé de me dire mais ça en fait je
connais pas et puis j'ai découvert petit
à petit qu'il y avait d'autres choses
encore et en fait fil en aiguille on
s'intéresse à ce phénomène des des
anciens spages locaux et puis après ça
devient un peu une passion chercheur de
trésor au cœur des vignes François est
devenu une sorte d'historien local il
accompagne et conseille les vignerons il
leur apporte son expertise
nous voici sur les cotaux du
valdecher là on est devant des des
Orbois qu'on appelle aussi le menu Pino
c'est un
nopage vraiment locaux dont on a des des
mentions des la fin du Moyen-Âge à la
Renaissance c'est page emblématique mais
qui a qui a beaucoup régressé sur les 30
40 dernières années et c'est bien de
voir des des vieilles souches comme ça
une belle diversité c'est puis là on
peut les goûter donc c'est c'est
top Laurence a repris l'exploitation
fondée par son
grand-père sur 14 hectares 8 spages se
côtoi les traditionnels sauvignons gamé
ou caberné et de vieilles parcelles de
gros lot d'orbois ou de mélier
Saint-François c'est une richesse on a
vu qu'on pouvait mettre en valeur nos
sépages donc notamment la pinodonice et
horbois et que ça faisait des vins
intéressants donc on les vinifie surtout
en monosépage et on a vu que ça
apportait vraiment de la typicité
typicité du sépage et ça permettait de
se différencier
aussi car le paysage viticole régional a
particulièrement évolué ces 60 dernières
années avant 1958 les CPAGE dit rare
aujourd'hui représentai plus de 60 % du
vignoble pour des raisons de
productivité et de rentabilité ils ont
été supplantés leur proportion est
désormais réduite à 15
% pourtant leur potentiel demeure intact
chacun avait son territoire spécifique
le gros entouren le mélier saint-fançois
dans le Loiré ou encore le genouiller au
confin du Cher et de l'Indre le
genouiller en voici d'ailleurs quelques
rangs replantés ici il y a à peine 2 ans
je c'est la première fois que j'en goûte
c'est assez émouvant en fait tout le
travail qu'on fait sur sur ces vieux
sépages parce
que on redonne une dimension historique
à des choses qui ont existé fut un temps
nouvelle aventure on va voir l'année
prochaine ce que ça va
donner retour sur
l'orbois tout juste
vendanger un bon 12 et demi donc c'est
très bien bonne
maturité l'ambition de Laurence
exploiter la richesse présente la
valorisé au nom du devoir de mémoire
mais aussi parce que l'époque l'impose
et C Bages qui ont été en arrêt de
culture à un moment donné parce qu'il
n'avait plus de débouché ou parce que
c'était plus au bout du consommateur
aujourd'hui parce que peut-être le
climat a changé peut-être qu'on est dans
d'autres manières de produire de
vinifier on retrouve des vins qui mais
qui séduisent le consommateur
aussi rest sur
cette mais d'où proviennent les noms de
ces appellations
oubliées leur histoire est intimement
liée à la Loire comme celle du
[Musique]
gros la grole c'est un synonyme du du
merle par exemple Merlot identifie
effectivement la cou couleur du sépage
en noir et le grosot c'est parce que
c'est un sépage très noir donc on l'a
appelé grosot les dénominations sont
ainsi issues soit de la forme du sépage
soit de sa couleur ou encore de la
localisation de son
terroir c'est vrai que bah grolo ou Pino
se termine par e auu où on peut prendre
des noms communs comme Moro bretono
trousseau Velpo c'est en euau et c'est
vrai que sur les Pinau de l'Est ça va
s'écrire
ça donne une idée d'un ancrage
géographique avec la terminaison des des
des
noms nous voici dans le vend d'ois le
berceau de l'appellation Pino de Nice
sur le flan de ces collines des ces de
vignes particulièrement
exceptionnel on contemple des vignes
historiques puisque c'est des pieds de
Pino de Nice qui ont été plantés autour
de
189 c'est ça 0 ça force le respect c'est
vraiment chouette à voir quand on VO des
des belles grappes comme
ça c'est un sépage qui a qui a bien qui
est bien adapté en fait au changement
climatique he c'est un spage
semi-tardif 3 heectares et demi de
vignes centenair qui ont échappé au
philoxera au milieu du 19e
siècle face au dérèglement climatique
elle révèle encore aujourd'hui des
capacités d'adaptation
extraordinaires c'est quand même ça
résistance moi je trouve phénoménal aux
maladies voilà une année quand même de
mil
d'idium l'pinodonice quand vous avez
bien maîtrisé la situation à la vigne
voyez il est il a bien résisté quoi et
voilà le résultat
[Musique]
parfait dégustation de la CUV 2022 dans
le CH trogloditique
familial
des tin fin des tin présent encore mais
des beanin
bien pas marqué par la canicule c'est
rest frais pierrefrançois incarne la 9e
génération de cette famille de
viticulteur une histoire indissociable
de celle du Pino de Nice au grré du
temps et des tendances ça c page qu'en
fait qui qui peut le meilleur qui peut
le pire il a connu le pire avec la
chimie les engrais il connaî le meilleur
aujourd'hui avec la biodynamie et
l'agriculture biologique en fait c'est
un très très vieux spage français qui a
failli disparaître
que qu'on a relancé dans les années 80
aujourd'hui c'est phénoménal parce que
partout on nous demande du pinonis y
compris au Japon aux États-Unis en
Australie le renouveau de cet ancien
sépage s'explique donc en parti par
l'évolution des attentes des
consommateurs en moins de 15 ans les
Collins ont conquis le marché par
parisien et exportent aujourd'hui 25 %
de leur production du Brésil à la Corée
de l'Italie au
Canada je pense que c'est la nouvelle
génération de consommateurs aussi ils
sont vraiment ouverts à des choses
qu'ils connaissent pas et donc du coup
les spages anciens dont le pinod Nice
bah on un tout majeur quoi c'est vrai
que l'ancienne génération était plutôt
sur leurs acquis et aujourd'hui on voit
que les jeunes s'intéressent vraiment
aux choses nouvelles aux nouvelles
méthodes de culture au nouveau nouveaux
mais en fait ancien c'est page et donc
du coup l'appellation et Pinon est tout
à fait dedans quoi tout ce qui est
clientellele étrangère notamment
asiatique s'intéresse énormément au
nouveau goût et surtout avec une culture
culinaire qui est complètement
différente de ce qu'on connait en Europe
et donc du coup quand on leur propose un
pin dece qui qui est légèrement épicé
poivré bah ça colle parfaitement avec
leur gastronomie ils adorent
[Musique]
quoi
le pinodonis a conservé sa certification
AOP c'est une exception parmi les
sépages oublié car certains ont
quasiment
disparu viens voir un peu ce que ça
donne voici de jeunes pieds de lignage
87 planté en 2022 et autant au printemps
dernier mais ce de l'année passée on
vachement poussé tout le bois é tout le
bois est
nickel c'est un spage de d'ici qui qui
avait complètement disparu donc il y
avait deux souches existantes de lignage
et on est reparti de ces deux souches
pour essayer de reconstruire un premier
vignoble une vigne mère qui va servir à
tous mes collègues ensuite à replanter
pour réimpplanter ce spage
ici considéré comme noble au 15e siècle
il avait été abandonné car peu productif
il renaî aujourd'hui dans le Loir et
Cher sans que l'on sache vraiment
quelles seront ses caractéristiques
aromatique tous ceux qui en ont bu sont
morts les la viille ay officiellement
disparu dans les années 50 je pense que
j'ai j'ai pas aucun témoin quand on les
a planté l'année dernière il y avait
quand même de l'émotion parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un petit monument
historique qu'on mettait en terre et
comme disait Thierry c'est vrai que
personne n'a goûté on est totalement sur
sur l'inconnu et en même temps c'est un
défi c'est c'est un challenge c'est
génial de voir là ce témoin vivant euh
avec aucune perte c'est c'est c'est très
très
positif il y avait quelques grappes tout
le long du rang mais elles ont été
mangées par les
chevreilles
mais j'aime bien euh j'aime bien le goût
que ça bah on remercie les Ch d'avoir
quand même laissé une grappe ouais c'est
c'est gentil c'est qu'ils ont
apprécié mais comment a-t-on retrouvé
ces ses
originel ils proviennent d'un
conservatoire comme celui de Montreuil
bé dédié au vignobl du valde Loire ici
sont conservés les souches mè parmi
elles une douzaine de ces pages
patrimoniaux ils y sont étudiés de
l'élevage à la dégustation une dizaine
de jours
on va les suivre donc au niveau des
caractéristiques phénologiques le
débourement la floraison la verraison
des caractéristiques agronomique le
rendement et ensuite jusqu'au
vinification pour pouvoir faire un
dossier d'inscription dans les
prochaines années du lignage au au
catalogue retour sur l'exploitation de
la famille puzela un domaine mené en
fratterie avec les filles de
Thierry alors d'ù Dou Dou Dou Dou
[Musique]
ici on s'attache à une philosophie bien
particulière la
biodiversité loin des mers de vignes le
domaine compte 18 sépages sur 18
hectares une parcelle bio comme celle-ci
est entouré de bois des herbé l'hiver
par les brebis et à proximité de ruches
et de plantations aromatiques ça nous
permet de pouvoir faire le plus
d'expérimentations possible d'essayer
des nouveaux assemblages de changer de
parcell d'en utiliser une dans une autre
et puis d'avoir au-delà même de la
viinification la possibilité de faire
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres choses en
parallèle de la vigne les fruitiers les
abeilles les brebis tout un tas de
projets qui seraient pas possible si on
se concentrait pas autour de la
vigne une approche à l'image de la
réhabilitation de CC pages oublié des
passionnés é viignnerons tournés vers
l'avenir avec les trésors du passé on
espère bien faire rentrer dans notre
communauté de de nouveaux
adeptes qui après prêche la bonne parole
en tout cas mais en tout cas c'est un
groupe très ouvert et il y a du dialogue
qui est vraiment intéressant entre
toutes les personnes
qui qui font partie de cette dynamique
il y a beaucoup d'échanges qui sont
faits sans doute plus que dans le monde
du vin en règle
générale
y